monsieur thiébaut merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france
je voulais que vous réagissiez on a
entendu un sur notre antenne il ya
quelques minutes alexandre langlois qui
a décidé de quitter la police ici est
engagée pour protéger les français les
libertés individuelles aujourd'hui la
quitte car elle a constaté trop de
dysfonctionnements
autre action réaction c'est que il ne
sert à rien de quitter la police pour
pouvoir pour vouloir la changer
la police de la république ce n'est pas
une personne ce n'est pas des individus
la police de la république c'est une
institution
elle est là pour défendre la loi pour la
faire appliquer et s'il ya des brebis
galeuses il faut les dégager de la
police et le problème qu'on veut
aujourd'hui entière pour la police
nationale
c'est que le travail n'est pas faire
pour retirer les brebis galeuses dont il
ne sert à rien de démissionner de la
police pour vouloir dénoncer la police
dans tout état de droit
ils font un moment une police pour faire
respecter les lois et faire respecter
les libertés
on dirait pas de police c'est l'anarchie
c'est la loi du plus fort donc moi je
suis attaché à la cuisine est votre
position concernant cette loi c'est
quand était globale et notamment cet
article 24 un kyste à lisa toute
l'attention un article qui dit c'est
lent travail de sanctionner de pénaliser
la diffusion malveillantes d'image de
policiers la position elle est toujours
la même c'est à dire que cette
proposition de loi elle est tombé de
nulle part pour faire plaisir à certains
parlementaires la république en marche
elle a même pas été soumise au contrôle
du conseil d'état sur le conseil d'état
va donner un avis va dire si le projet
de la proposition de loi est
constitutionnelle ou pas et elle a été
tout de suite voté sans même s'assurer
derrière qu'elle respectait les droits
fondamentaux mais c'est ça qu'est ce
qu'on va lui le problème de l'article 24
sais que vous allez pernette pendant une
manifestation à des policiers de pouvoir
arrêter toute personne qui viendra à
filmer une action de police et à partir
de ce moment là c'est totalement tout à
fait ce qu'on a lu parce que le droit
d'informer là
certaines espèces comme la liberté de la
presse ou totalement travail et les
modifications qui sont proposées par le
gouvernement ne change rien à cette
disposition qui permettra à la victime
potentielle à dire aux policiers de
pouvoir être l'acteur du respect de la
loi c'est-à-dire d'être la personne qui
pourra interpeller la personne qui soit
disant est en train de la filmer pour la
diffuser de manière malveillante
donc moi je suis totalement opposé à cet
article